more than a thousand children most of
them girls are locked in mental health
units many run by private companies
under regimes that are not always
specialists I was subjected to very very
brutal restraints its staff who can
struggle to keep them safe or believed
that my young person was going to die
there and often miles from home and
family if something did happen you would
never get there in time these companies
they are being run to maximize profit
the NHS spends hundreds of millions of
pounds buying care from private
providers but are they putting profit
before patients
when I'm stressed and whenever used to
run away my mum would always say Natasha
is on the swings and I'd always could
find a swing and I just gonna sit on it
that's what I needed was just meant to
calm me down
natasha is rebuilding her life after a
lost decade a walk in the park with her
partner amy is the sort of simple
pleasure she was denied when she was
confined to mental health units with
problems including anorexia and
escalating self-harm that began when she
was 12
Newtown Signet from our house Cigna
Bradford she spent 10 years in mental
health units dotted across the country
and reached her lowest point after being
transferred to a privately run Hospital
in Maidenhead when I got there my self
harming instead of decreasing increased
to probably the worst amounts of
self-harm that had ever done in my life
to the point where on one occasion I had
to have over 200 stitches I was left
unattended I'd hidden a load of razors
which was supposed to be taken off of me
on like like on my return to the
hospital and that they weren't and I
managed to cut myself probably about 36
times probably more and I hit arteries
and so for that
she says physical restraint was common I
was subjected to very very brutal
restraints some that stick in my mind to
this day they pin you up against walls
smack your head off the wall they drag
you across floors they'd wrap you around
door frames you'd have people pretty
much sat on your head
sat on your legs and these would be like
big big man not just not just women
Natasha sued the hospital run by private
company the Hunter Kuhn group and was
awarded significant damages for their
failure to provide appropriate
psychiatric treatment and for allowing
episode
of self-harm the hunter groom group told
us they apologized for her care Natasha
says her compensation was a fraction of
the amount the NHS paid to subcontract
her care to private hospitals my
Commissioner was a lovely woman she
referred to me as a Million Dollar Baby
because they made millions out of the
NHS for my care Natasha is not alone
there are 1282
under a teens admitted to inpatient
units across England 927 of them the
girls these units have specially
commissioned Child and Adolescent Mental
Health Services or Cam's they're paid
for by NHS England but often privately
run private providers were paid one
hundred and fifty six point five million
pounds by NHS England for beds or
specialist care in 2017-18 that's 44
percent of the total Cam's specialist
budget Kier Harding is an occupational
therapist who works as a consultant to
NHS organisations and private companies
the things that jump out at me from what
the Care Quality Commission say about
private providers in this area is that a
private placement will last twice as
long as an NHS placement so there is
concern from the CQC that some of the
places that market themselves a
specialist units are actually just
locked rehab units where people are
we're housed rather than there being an
intense effort to make changes in their
lives in their promotional videos
private providers promised the highest
standards of care we aspire to nurture
in the world one person at a time but
Sky News analysis shows that they are
less likely than their NHS equivalents
to be rated highly we looked at Care
Quality Commission inspection reports
for hospitals run by the five largest
private recipients of NHS funding
compiled since 2016 88% of those run by
NHS trusts were rated as good or
outstanding compared to just 58 percent
of those run by the largest
private providers no private unit had an
overall rating of outstanding five were
rated inadequate the lowest grade the
CQC can give and since 2017 five
privately run units have closed
following critical CQC reports one of
those inadequate hospitals was here
Whatcom hall in Torquay owned and run by
the Hunter Kuhn group it's one of four
mental health hospitals the company has
closed in the last year as its parent
company faces financial difficulties
that last month saw it go into
administration a Sky News investigation
has uncovered concerns about the
standard of care provided here and at
another of its units in Devon in May
2017 inspectors from the Care Quality
Commission came here and they delivered
a damning verdict they found multiple
failures of patient care and concluded
that wacom Hall was not safe for
patients the Hunter Kuhn group were
given six months to improve the service
but instead decided to close this
hospital now Sky News understands that
what went on here is the subject of a
police investigation the investigation
is understood to relate to a former
employee and the Crown Prosecution
Service say they're awaiting a full case
file from the police
after Whatcom hall closed the hunter
[ __ ] group opened a new unit a few miles
away called meadow Lodge last month it
also closed with the hunter goon group
blaming a lack of demand but former
employees have told us the unit was
unsafe and short-staffed
Ian Summers is an experienced mental
health nurse who's worked with the
highest security patients at Broadmoor
Hospital
he says Meadow Lodge had a culture of
self-harm among adolescent girls
including the use of ligatures a means
of strangulation I've got a young person
banging their head against a wall I'm
gonna be a person cut in and I got
another person with ligature well I
don't have all the staff to respond to
all these young people so after I have
to risk assess and respond to the one in
in you know what it's not closer to
death really we all believed my young
person was going to die there and we
responded to the ligature first then
they cut him and a headband you know you
imagine that all these young people
being left in this crisis it's just not
right we didn't have enough staff we
didn't have enough trained staff and we
had nothing for these young people
that's why they were restrained because
there was nothing for them
Ian says he was sacked after raising
concerns that staff were being
encouraged to downplay incidents that
should have been reported colleague
Chris Tremlett a healthcare assistant at
Meadow Lodge resigned after seeing some
of the treatment leakages were haven't
entirely continually Daly saying with
restraints were happening daily it was
just too much we didn't have the staff
to cope with the unknown that was going
on there personally for myself it was
upsetting to see you know these are
children at the end of the day nobody
wants to be physically holding a child
you know it shouldn't be happening in my
eyes but we got to do what we were told
to do
mental health units maybe closing but
there is no shortage of patients and
parents requiring support one measure of
demand is the number of children who end
up being treated far from home and
Families it is a particular problem here
in the southwest where we went to see a
support group of parents who have
first-hand experience to say hey dude
John how I at least me we through here
these parents all have daughters in
crisis and they meet once a month to
share their experiences John and Vicki's
daughter has been treated in 10
different mental health units in the
last five years eight of them privately
run we've missed our daughter growing up
before last five six years but when you
see her now even though she's 18 years
old now and in the adult services what
sometimes when she's talking she's still
about 13 your girl left you over me you
wake up every morning and you think is
this gonna be well first of all you
think if she's still alive and then when
you find out things all right as it can
be your next thought is will she managed
to achieve our aim today and you are
hundreds of miles away from her and if
something did happen you would never get
there in time David Marianne's daughter
is more than three hours drive away and
they believe the use of private
hospitals is failing children these
companies they're there there are profit
making they're beholden to their
shareholders and so they are being run
to maximize profit so that's where you
have the constant staff shortages we did
under stuff for that with the only stuff
this isn't it happen well where's the
stuff all we didn't have enough well the
money you're being given paid for this
that's not an excuse never excuse them
about money that that's been put into
this it's it's almost a mother's put
money Kier Harding believes the current
system has to change what is it that
means that the NHS feel the need to send
people away because it's not like
providers exist in a vacuum
they're responding to a market that's
there
and then we can kind of think well why
are these placements lasting so long is
it because private providers want to
garrage money out of people and that's a
really easy accusation to make but again
we also need to think about well why an
NHS organisations trying to get people
home harder the hunter goon group
declined a request for interview but
told Sky News all of Iain summers
allegations about Meadow Lodge were
thoroughly investigated and that not all
of mr. summers concerns were found to be
accurate separately mr. summers was
dismissed for gross misconduct
last month the Huntington group's parent
company Four Seasons Healthcare went
into administration but they told us a
deal with creditors meant its services
would remain open and it had had no
bearing on the closure of services the
decision to close any of our hospitals
is always extremely difficult and always
the last resort and is often the result
of a number of local factors having
experienced a decline in the demand for
isolated services in three rural
locations coupled with well-documented
issues of qualified nurse resource
availability across the sector we
concluded that these services were not
sustainable a decision made pre any
administration process all of our Kam's
services are rated as good by the CQC
these allegations and historical
incidents do not provide a true or
accurate reflection of the high standard
of care they provide everyday health
secretary Matt Hancock and NHS England
declined to be interviewed or answer our
questions about child and adolescent
mental health services but in a
statement NHS England said it has opened
more beds in acute units and expects
private providers to offer safe good
quality care feed the pigeons things
Natasha offers hope for young people and
families in the midst of mental health
crises now at university she's training
to be an occupational therapist using
her experience of a system that took a
terrible toll on her friends I've lost
24 friends to suicide about 24
three or four of them were in one unit
specifically it's like a whole classroom
of people I lost to the illness she says
the key to recovery was finding a doctor
willing to trust her the doctor that had
sex with me five years previous to
Hunter Combe I ended up being back on
his unit again he couldn't believe I
still in the same section and I said I
just want to go home at this point my
home had changed and my parents have
relocated and he said okay we'll give it
a go
and he moved me he he took me off my
section and he moved my care to where my
parents live now and I got to go home it
was the first time anyone in all my
treatment had actually listened to me
and what I wanted and he gave me that
chance and he sent me home